hi there today we'll look at nua visual
synthesis pre-training for neural visual
world creation this is by researchers of
microsoft research asia and peking
university the paper presents a model
that can support a wide variety of image
generation tasks such as text to image
where you give a piece of text and you
get an image this is a dog with goggles
staring at the camera
up to something like video manipulation
where you want to change the frames of a
video according to a piece of text for
example the car is reversing instead of
the car is driving forward now you see
there's not always text in the loop
sometimes it's just an image sometimes
it's a sketch
sometimes it's just a video so all of
these kinds of tasks are supported by
this model and this paper goes into how
the model's architecture is done
specifically how the
a transformer architecture essentially
an attention mechanism is able to handle
such large data points essentially
contexts not only going to images but
beyond images to multiple frames of
video
hey all this video is sponsored by clear
ml clear ml is an ml ops stack that is
fully open source it can do experiment
tracking experiment orchestration
deployment it has model and features
stores it is a complete package of ml
tools now what i want to highlight in
particular here is this self-hosted tier
self-hosted is a first-class citizen for
clear ml everything's open source
therefore you can look at it you can
audit it you can extend it however you
want and you can host it on your servers
there's also a free tier that is
available in the cloud so you can get
started with whatever you need in the
cloud and then once you need more
features you can go to a more
professional setup if you don't want to
self host if you love open source then
clear ml might be the way to go it is an
end to end stack from experimentation
all the way to serving it's vertically
integrated makes your life a whole lot
easier and it is appropriate whether you
are an individual running experiments or
an entire team now one of the core
pieces of clear ml is of course their
experiment tracker it's super easy to
set up it needs like a single line of
code i guess that's two lines but you
know who cares it integrates with pretty
much any tool there is and not only does
it record your metrics like you're used
to it also fully grabs all the console
output of your experiments it grabs any
artifacts that iran might have produced
and most importantly it clearly records
not only your hyper parameters but also
the other parameters of your environment
such as the path and the machine you run
it on and your dependencies another
really cool feature is that it allows
you to compare different experiments for
example here it shows you what part of
their configuration was different so
you're able to pretty quickly figure out
what made the difference in any
particular run and of course you can
grab a bunch of experiments together and
then analyze them next to each other so
now there's no excuse anymore for
blaming your tools any fault in your
machine learning project will be yours
and yours alone if you use clear ml
isn't that a promise so i invite you to
go over and check it out at
clear.ml and thanks so much to clearml
for sponsoring this video and let's get
into it
[Music]
so
yeah we'll go into the paper we'll see
how they do it i do find
this this opening thing right here is a
little bit overstated because a lot of
these things aren't coming out of the
same model but the model is then
fine-tuned on different things and i
also find that paper is a bit unclear on
some of the details
and if i understand correctly there is
no code yet that we can look at maybe
that's going to be released maybe not
who knows
um to the name nua is
you know there's this umlaut which we do
have in german but i don't believe this
is a german uh german-inspired name or
or or any sort of nordic language uh i
do believe this comes from the symbol in
pinyin that has also is represented as
an umlaut on the
u um it took me like so long to figure
out that you have to type a v in pinyin
to get that output i i just couldn't
spell
uh words like new
for a long time but now i can so i do
believe this is pronounced nua
uh but correct me if i'm wrong also many
thanks to andreas who helped me prepare
this paper a little bit
gave me some inputs this is very much
appreciated
follow andreas on twitter
he also often posts
updates for our paper discussions on
discord so very helpful thank you all
right let's get into it
so this model is
something like an image gpt model if you
know image gpt image gpt is essentially
similar like a pixel rnn where you have
an image you want to produce the image
sort of pixel by pixel left to right top
to bottom you produce just one pixel
after another after another after
another and you learn this
how you would learn a language model
essentially just pixel by pixel and you
can support tasks like completing images
where you simply give
you ev everything here you are already
set
precomputed and you simply let the model
in for these pixels right here or you
can support things like image
manipulation by simply you have a
picture right here and
or i'll say that's the cat
and you simply cut out part of the image
so you cut out this part or something
you let the model fill it in so you
could do things like in painting or
something like this
this is supported by image gpt now the
problem
with something like image gpt is that if
you want to have this as sort of a
language generation task then your
context size is you know if you predict
the
pixel on the bottom right here the
context is like all the pixels
in the rest of the image that you've
already generated and if you have
something like a 200 by 200
image that is 4 000 uh previous pixels
now 4 000 is
just about no is it it's 40 000 sorry
sorry about that 40 000 that is
definitely outside of the scope of every
transformer uh that we have and beyond
that if we now look at video and video
is essentially just a stack of images
right so you have an image frame
the next frame
and the next frame
if you look at that if you want to
produce a single pixel right here not
only do you have to take into account
all of the pixels of the image that
you've generated so far but also all of
the pixels of the previous frames that
you've generated so far right and that
definitely blows the context of any
transformer that is infeasible so this
model here very much is about how do we
make this feasible the answer is going
to be a two-fold
first of all we're going to encode all
of the data into a common space that is
uh kind of discrete in latent space and
is way less dimensional and the second
answer is going to be we're going to use
local attention
in order
to work in this latent space and finally
generate the output
so this is an overview over the model i
do find it a little bit uh lacking uh as
a picture but you can see that
in general we use these encoders and the
encoders they take care of bringing the
data whatever the data is into a common
representation right here
the common representation is going to be
a essentially a three-dimensional
cube where each element is an embedding
vector
but we're going to look at that
now
so
how do we encode text our goal is to our
goal is going to be to have a latent
space to have an encoder for any kind of
data
and after the encoder the data should be
in sort of a latent space and that
latent space should be
if possible
it's kind of discrete or quantized i'm
going to use we're going to use some
methods that already exist but for text
that's pretty easy for text the encoder
is simply it can be the identity
function right
because if i have a piece of text like
a cat
whatever
if i tokenize that text that is already
tokens so right now if we make if we do
language modeling or any sort of
language processing the first step is
tokenizing the text and then associating
each token with an embedding vector so
this is going to be nice it's going to
be a set or a sequence of tokens
and that's exactly the representation
that we want so for text everything's
good we have a sequence of tokens we
have a code book usually which is
sometimes in case language modeling
that's called the embedding
matrix that's at the beginning of the
model so every
every
code vector every token is associated
with a vector so we can look up that
vector in the code book replace
the token by the vector
and then process the tokens as vector
embeddings in the subsequent model
we want to do the same with images
right we want to get an image and we
want to bring it into the latent space
as a set of discrete quantized tokens
luckily there is a technique how you can
do that and that's called vqvae
so if i have an image
let's say again our cat
what i want to do is i want to have an
encoder
such that it results in a set of latent
tokens now vqva is interesting because
what the result is going to be is going
to be it's going to be like an image but
that image is going to be very low
dimensional so
here we may have 200 by 200 but over
here in this case we have like three by
three and these aren't in fact pixels
but they are tokens so these will be
vector quantized there will be a code
book they call it b
and that code book
will be
vectors for each token and what the
encoder does is it essentially reduces
the image down to
a representation that is three by three
and then every single pixel in that
three by three matrix every single entry
right here is going to be clamped to the
nearest entry in the code book that's
the quantization step if you if you
don't know much about this
you can look up vector quantized vector
quantized anything pretty much but
vector quantized vae is sort of the the
main reference right here it's the
encoder and codes in a continuous
fashion and then there is a
discontinuous step a discrete step where
we say
okay we there is there's latent space
and we have this codebook vectors here
and they're going to live in that latent
space as vectors as points in that
latent space and if my encoder encodes
an image
and i take any pixel right here and that
pixel might come to be here
i don't use the pixel or i don't use
this latent token as is i'm going to
clamp it to the value
directly of that code book vector so all
i end up with
is a selection of these code book
vectors so at each point here
there will be one of those code book
vectors and i can equivalently say if i
like number them this is one two three
four i can equivalently say these are
essentially tokens so token one might be
this might be this might be one this
might be two and two
three four four four four right
and from this
i can then have a decoder again
um
that produces back an image and the
image of course is now only produced
from this latent encoding you might
think that is way restrictive
but it actually turns out to be very
very powerful so instead of using the
exact encoding we use the quantized
encoding and if our code book is large
enough
you know you can encode quite a number
of things like if you have a thousand
tokens you can imagine token one could
be you know there's a there's kind of a
tree and token two is like a tree stump
and token three is like
well a tree that is like a has needles
like a needle needle like a pine
um and so on and then your latent
description here just kind of roughly
outlines the broad shape of the image so
not necessarily exactly what's where but
it just says like you know in the top
right there's a bunch of pine trees and
in the bottom right there's a road and
so on
so it's it's a latent tokenized or
latent discrete uh tokenized uh
representation
of the image here
and you can already see that this is way
beneficial because now we're only
working in a nine dimens sorry in nine
tokens whereas here it's 200 by 200 now
we don't have to forget that each of the
also each of these tokens obviously is
going to be associated with the vectors
with a vector so this is not nine
dimensional space but it's nine times
whatever the vector dimension is that is
associated with each token as
you know like this is not 200 by 200
it's actually 200 by 200 by 3
since every pixel has a vector of
dimension three associated to represent
color
right this vq vae
is trained as an is if i understand
correctly this is the first part where
the model that the paper isn't exactly
clear
uh what happens right here i'm not sure
whether this is trained end-to-end or
whether they train the encoder and
decoder here ahead of time um because
they have different formulations they
say like after training this we do that
and
uh i'm not sure
but essentially they train it um
like so here is how you obtain the
latent representation
you send an image that's i through the
encoder that's e and then you select the
z the these are the latent uh vectors
select the z or
the
now these are the the tokens the token
indices
such that
you select the z according to
what's the closest vector from the code
book from the code book b so you can see
that j or the indices into the code book
so the z
will be
for for token i
what
z i will be what entry in the code book
vector is closest to that representation
that the encoder produced
and then the reconstructed image i hat
is simply going to be i now go with my
latent representation to the code book i
actually get out the vectors the entries
of the code book i shove that into the
decoder which is g the generator i guess
and that gives me the reconstructed
image so how am i going to train this
it's easy i want that my produced image
is close to the original image right
here
i also want to train the code book which
is b to be
close to what my encoder produces so i
want the code book to be useful and that
means the code book needs to be able to
sort of just describe
the things that the encoder produces
right so the code i'm going to draw the
code book closer to the encoder's output
right here the sg is a stop gradient
which means that this part of the loss
affects the codebook
but also we have the symmetric part
right here where we're going to teach
the encoder
to produce things that are better
encodable by the code book so here the
stop gradient is on the code book which
means that this part of the loss affects
the encoder it's quite common to split
up two losses even though this could be
in one loss right
since it's symmetric it's quite common
to split it up into two parts each one
having a stop gradient makes things more
stable
all right so is this actually yeah
probably
um
it's it's just a framework framework
specifics right here i don't think ssg
is a valid mathematical thing anywhere
um this really refers to these stop
gradient functions in in tensorflow or
in pi torch
in addition to that they say well the vq
vae
is sort of too strict a little bit so
there is an extension called vqgan
that changes the vqva objective a little
bit so they say they add two things
right here one is a
gan loss which i'm going to guess is
this one right here so you can see they
introduce a discriminator that
discriminates between real and fake
images and i'm going to guess that that
here is the loss
for the discriminator right because you
want the discriminator to recognize
real from fake which means you need i
and i hat
um
but i don't see i don't see the loss
that would be added to the generator
because the generator's loss i don't
think that would necessarily include the
true
image
but i might be wrong because
yeah
so i mean the generator would simply not
care about
the first part right there if even if
you included it
but you know they introduce a
discriminator
which we know can help and they also say
they introduce a perceptual loss and i
simply write this down as we're going to
pass both the original image and the
generated image through a cnn and then
we compare the two this is in contrast
to comparing the two images directly as
you can see they say that this is um
meant to ease the exact constraints
between i and i hat and focus on high
level semantic matching i don't exactly
know what the cnns are if they are
trained as well or if they simply take
like an off the shelf resnet50 pass the
images through and compare the last
layers in in order to say well i just
want the latent representations to be
similar i don't actually want the images
to be similar
they also don't say whether that
replaces this this loss up here or
whether that's simply in addition to
that loss
again
we don't know
they further they further
say that
[Music]
you could do the same thing for videos
right you could train like a vq vae vq
gan for videos because after all videos
are just a
stack here that we saw a stack of of
images
but they say that didn't work out well
so what they do is they simply treat
each frame of the video as an image and
they pass each frame through this image
encoder right here and they simply stack
the outputs or they stack the latent
representations so that be from the
first frame then from the second frame
from the third frame and so on they
stack them
like this
and that gives you sort of a tensor now
keep in mind every single entry right
here
for example this entry or this entry or
this entry every single entry is
associated with a vector so this is
ultimately and
going to end up in a four dimensional
latent tensor that you work with
but we can represent it as a
three-dimensional tensor of tokens
where each token
will be an entry in the code book
so how is that a common representation
we saw so the text is
1d of tokens or 2d if you consider
it as vectors images are 2ds tokens but
3d as vectors and video is 3d as tokens
and 4d as vectors
how can we make sense of this and we
combine all of this by simply
introducing
dummy dimensions so if you've ever in
like numpy
you know you you index your vector
uh sorry
vector x with like um
you know i want everything everything
and none
right that that's one way you can also
use the expand dimms or unsqueezing pi
torch or anything like this to make it
compatible and essentially
use the broadcasting functionality of
the frameworks that's essentially what
they do here they say you know we we
have an image we have the latent
representation we simply add the um
placeholder dimension of one since
images have no temporal dimension it's
just height and width
but for videos this one would be i guess
not a one so if you can bring them into
the same space by using dummy dimensions
and broadcasting if necessary
so now everything essentially is a 4d
latent tensor you can bring in
um text you can bring in images you can
bring in videos
the next thing we want to do and again i
don't know if these are pre-trained the
encoder decoder or if these are trained
uh jointly i i don't know
the next thing we want to know is okay
right now this is simply encoding and
then if we ship the representation
through the decoder
it's right so if we ship it through the
encoder and then through the decoder
it's going to result in the same image
or in a very similar image right so here
is going to be like another cat like how
does that help us obviously there needs
to be something different right we want
an image right here i'm going to put it
through the encoder want to get its
latent representation and then we need
to do something
something with the latent representation
get another latent representation then
decode that
and then we get some sort of a different
result right so different resulting
image right here so this is the same for
like image completion and so on the
question obviously is what happens right
here
now
there is where
the uh
sort of the the transform or the
attention layers come in until now we've
had classic i think these are these are
convnets and so on these encoders
decoders
like you'd be used to if these are
images but now what we do is we
have
essentially a model that transforms
the
that transforms the latent
representation
to do meaningful work
okay so how is that how is that done
they differentiate two things right here
they differentiate context which is here
on the left broadly which they always or
sometimes denote with
large c
context
here
and as context they count things like
input text or input sketches
and the reason it's context is because
those things aren't output
those things are never given
incompletely the model will never have
to produce them you always input them
either you input them or you don't input
them but if you do input those things
it's conditioning information that the
model can look at as a whole right you
always enter the full text or the full
sketch you never enter like half a
sketch the model can't produce sketches
the model can only produce
images
or image frames
frames of a video
okay so that is the decoder is only
images encoders can be for text for
images and for sketches
so the part over here they would
generally call
the output y even if like half of it is
actual input into the algorithm so here
you can see the input is the uh part of
an image and the output is the remaining
part of that image or the input is the
video frame the output is the future
frames right so um
yeah so that is the output part this
should remind you sort of of the
original transformer architecture so the
sequence to sequence task is you have
sort of sequence one and that is always
given in full and then you have sequence
2 that
sequence 2 that maybe maybe you are
given not nothing at all or you're sort
of given an initial initial token right
here or you're given kind of a prefix of
what you have to generate and then you
have to go on completing sequence two
now if you don't have sequence one at
all that's a decoder only architecture
that's also possible you can condition
on nothing but the most general
architecture has these two sequences if
you remember the original transformer it
was exactly like this and then wait let
me
pull this down a bit
and then it had sort of a stack of
transfer of attention layers here
and a stack of attention layers right
here
and what you do is within the attention
blocks you'd have like self attention
where things attend to
each other attention here attention
attention attention and then
inside this block you'd had attention
also by with itself but then also you'd
had layers where attention would go from
the y part so from the output part to
the context part
so you would let the output right here
in a layer collect information from the
context by doing what they call cross
attention
in the original transformer paper i
think it's still called cross attention
right here both are the same operation
both are
both are attention operations it's just
a matter
you always have a queries and keys sorry
that's an e
and keys and values
if it's self-attention all of these are
generated from the same input and if
it's not self-attention then this for
example is generated from the y input
and these two are generated from the
context information and that essentially
means that y is requesting information
from c so y is looking is attending to
information in c
okay same thing here
what they they have this uh layer
called three dna now that's the entire
layer name is 3dna that is
3d nearby self attention okay
so
they say this is
based on the previous 3d data
representation so 3d
they essentially mean 4d but 3d
tokenized and then each token has a
vector
as a vector but there the 3d comes in
when they do when they discuss how they
do their attention
by nearby they essentially mean local
attention so what what they're going to
do is they're going to do local
attention in this 3d tensor that is
i think what i what i could gather so
far
they formulate this in a general way
right here so what you'll do is you'll
define this for two tensors x
and c
and
sometimes those are the same and
sometimes not so specifically x can be
either
c in which case it's self attention or x
can be y
in which case it is cross attention from
y to c
i guess c could also be y in which case
it is self attention from y to y
so uh yeah i'll just make it a little
bit confusing right here
in any case uh it's just a matter of
how how you compute um the
how you compute the keys the values and
the queries as you can see the queries
are the queries are always computed uh
from
the entire the queries are always
computed from the entire
vect or vector tensor x so whatever is
producing the query
the entire
thing is producing the query however for
the keys and values what you do is you
define a local neighborhood
so now we care specifically about how do
i produce y
at location i j k
you have to imagine we have this 3d
representation which is essentially a
big cube
that cube's elements are these tokens
right so this is
you can imagine it as a just stack of
video frames but in latent space right
so in latent space we have this stack of
video frames of the latent encodings of
the video frames if it's just a single
image right you broadcast and so on but
in in that case we wonder how from this
we need to produce sort of the next
layers representation which is also
going to be a cube just like it
so
as much as in an attention layer the
input is a sequence of tokens the output
is a sequence of tokens as well in this
it's the input is a
i guess a cube of tokens and the output
is again a cube of tokens
so how we're going to do that
we have
and
we produce
the output
for each location
we define a neighborhood so if we want
to predict this this would be y
at i j k
we're going to search i j k over here
which is going to be
i guess
right here okay so this is i j k
the same location
then we're going to define a local
neighborhood around that thing so that
could be
just it's again going to be a cube
um
like this that is just a little bit
bigger and
they are using as far as i can tell
they're using three by three by three
cubes right here so they're going to
define a neighborhood and while the
queries are generated from sort of the
entirety
right here of the
from the entirety of the tensor the keys
and values are only going to be computed
from that
cube
so instead if this is height width and
height no this is s let's call that as
the temporal dimension and width
even though this is already in the
latent space it would still be
very very expensive to compute
self attention or cross attention um
when every single element of the cube
attends to every single other element
right that's essentially what we'd have
to do in an attention layer in text i
have a sequence and
every
sort of every part of the sequence is
able to attend to every single other
part of the sequence that is
not feasible if you have a 3d cube even
if it's in a lower dimensional latent
space so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to say okay if i want to
if i want to compute this output right
here
i
can only attend to a local neighborhood
around this output here so
that's that's that so the queries i can
compute once for the whole tensor
but then if i so that's i can compute
the queries for the whole tensor but if
i want to produce a particular location
the only place i can attend to
is the keys and values of a particular
local neighborhood
so essentially that piece of the cube
here can only look at the local
neighborhood around its locations in
order to aggregate information
that is its local local attention
either local cross-attention or local
self-attention so we define the
neighborhood and uh produce the query
for a particular location
i'm not sure if if that should be x
ijk or not
um
not sure
but um
yeah you can see that the the keys and
the values are certainly specific to a
location they include this neighborhood
right here this n neighborhood the end
neighborhood is defined as uh this set
right here which is simply what i just
said that that cube
um and then i compute the soft max
simply as
and this is i think there's a mistake
right here this should be this should
definitely be um not here this should
definitely be here
um
yeah
so i'll compute the soft max like i
would in the outer product between
queries and keys
uh just in that neighborhood and then
aggregating the values according to what
the softmax of the routing table gives
me and that's how i produce this output
right here
okay so i can do that all in parallel i
can essentially produce that next tensor
right here of the latent representation
and
yeah that's that
now
i just said i i produce it all by the
way there is a you can see that reduces
the complexity from sort of this square
to
simply every location attending to its
local neighborhood
so that reduces the
complexity by quite a bit
so for every location
that's this part i have to attend to its
local neighborhood that's this part
there's also positional encodings as you
can see right here and what we're going
to do we're going to first have a stack
of layers of self attention for the
context like we saw in the original
transformer so we're first going to have
a stack of l layers right here and after
that we're going to have a stack of l
layers here and each of those l layers
can do either self attention or cross
attention but as far as i can tell it's
it's kind of different than the original
transformer because here you can see the
next layer
here is produced from the last layers
and likewise here if i produce the i the
next layer is produced from the last
layers of y
but also from cross attention from the
last layer of y to the l layer of c
which means that it it only can look at
the output layer so the arrows i've
drawn here can technically not happen
but it always has to look at like the
output layer up here i guess that's a
way to do it um i don't think that's the
exact same thing as in the original
transformer where you really have as i
shown the arrows here you sort of attend
to the same height
i might also be wrong in this
or it's a wrong formula right here that
is also completely
possible
now you can see there is i've
masked this there is also this part
right here so what we're going to use is
we're going to use causal attention
so we're only going to attend um i said
you can do it all at the same time you
have to do a causal mask you know like
in things like gpt where i produce one
token at a time um when i produce this
token right here i'm only allowed to
look at the token that i've already
produced
and that's the exact same right here in
fact we're going to produce this
representation we're going to start like
at the top left at time step one
and we're going to produce
the whole image at time step one pixel
or not pixel by pixel but um element by
element in this representation and then
we're going to once that is complete
that
video frame let's say we're going to go
to the next step and again do it element
by element so this is really a
giant auto regressive model now you can
with causal attention you can you can
train
at the same time but during inference
you only actually attend to the things
in front of you this formula in fact
doesn't
doesn't exactly i don't is this is this
correct
um because here it says everything needs
to be smaller which to me
would mean that you know if i'm let's
let's just make it for 2d and let's just
say it's smaller i smaller j it's the
question of if i produce this pixel
right here technically i should have
access to everything up here and the row
so far right but with this formula what
it would mean is that
i have access to
only whatever is to the top left of me
like this part right here
and i don't think that's the case i
think this is just sloppy notation right
here see yeah this denote the generated
tokens for now that i don't think is
correct
to express it like this
seems shady it's all it also doesn't
tell us exactly in which order the
pixels are produced um though i think
it's
first within a time step and then across
uh time steps
so
yeah that is
that is
that
now let's get to the training objective
so i hope you can see that this is one
layer
of this
three
dna
and we have l layers here and l i think
is 24 in their models we have l
layers on for the context and then also
layers of
cross and self-attention
and ultimately we end up up here with
the final representation
and training we can do in parallel with
causal masking
but in france we have to do element by
element
so that's why they praise that their
model is reasonably fast but i think
it's still like 50 seconds to produce
one one image or something like this
and that's why
so the training objective and here is a
little bit where they they
yeah where again i i find it to be quite
unclear
so they say they train it on three tasks
and if i understand correctly they train
on these three tasks
simultaneously
so they have three different data sets
one is
a
text to image data set where
you can see right here you produce an
image and you condition on text okay uh
you
and you can see that this lower than t
simply means the elements or the tokens
lower than t
um and you go from t equals one until
height times width so it's an image so
it only has these two dimensions so and
you produce um
i guess pixel by pixel
see that that i don't i don't know what
what does y mean here if it's really the
output y
then
um you know you have that generator here
and the generator probably doesn't go
pixel by pixel that
i i don't know maybe it does maybe it
actually does
um
in any case you have these three tasks
so one is text to image from a data set
that does that one is video prediction
where you simply input a piece of a
video here the c here that is like a no
op so that is
the special word none
so because you know you still have to
input something but if you have no text
conditioning you simply input a dummy
and then the loss goes over also over
the time steps and there is also text to
video where you'd input text and video
so far
and you'd output the rest of the frames
so that is
yeah
again so
here probably the loss doesn't
necessarily go across
all the time steps since part of the
video is already
given
um
but yeah i guess we'll have to wait for
the code to see what really turns out
most notably you can see that the
conditioning information right here
is sometimes it's video right because um
it's uh
sometimes video is kind of conditioning
implicitly by us already being part of
the output
but there is no for example sketch
conditioning right here it's always
either text or nothing
and
this is pre-training
so that means everything you see to do
with sketch is then fine-tuned so that
that was my when i first saw this i
thought like oh wow they you know train
this jointly everything's joint and
then the same model can do all of these
tasks and it turns out no actually most
of these things are then fine-tuned uh
down the line now they do show that the
fun the pre-training actually helps
quite a bit but
you have to understand these are in fact
fine-tuned also you can immediately see
that something like video manipulation
is not actually video manipulation like
the model doesn't care about about these
frames right here uh that the car what
the car is doing the model doesn't even
see this you simply input the first
frame and then you let it generate the
next frames based on this text right
here uh so it's not necessarily
manipulation as much as i give you the
beginning of a video in the piece of
text and now please
predict the video based on the text it's
a bit like this here except you already
have
the first frame uh if if i understand
correctly um but i think i think i do
there's really no other way
i guess i'm not sure
maybe they actually input into
maybe they input it into the context
right here
but i cannot imagine
that
in any case maybe i completely
misunderstand this right here
but these are the tasks they give some
implementation uh detail about how the
um how the latent
spaces or you can see that there's a
latent space of
dimension
1200 and
um
yeah the local neighborhood is of size
three by three by three or three by
three bro one for
images when they're lonely images
and it's the regular attention mechanism
if it is text
all right so that is
it and these the next slides are results
experimental results i
want to highlight a few so here are
things they can do they compare for
example with dali which is a model that
is explicitly trained to produce images
from text right whereas this model right
here is sort of uh
a multi-purpose model and you can see
that in general either the results are
comparable um
or better i mean it's this is at this
point it's kind of
arguable you can measure it on certain
data sets uh for example um here
they uh
they specifically
praise this picture right here where
they say oh this is very clear and
consistent and this other
state-of-the-art model
is not as
not as good
um
i do like some of these outputs right
here
playing golf on grass the baseline model
you can see the baseline model just just
screws up though i do think
there aren't many d for some tasks there
are just no
no baselines available because they kind
of invented them
themselves
but you can see that
when there's baselines available the
baselines
usually they either
yeah they don't necessarily
do so well
either so in this case this is doesn't
really seem to be
yeah
i guess it's some kind of a human-ish
thing
um
but this you know looks looks fairly
neat and you can see the resolution is
also bigger than the resolutions of the
competitors that's that's pretty cool um
you can also as i said this is now
fine-tuned right
if you actually want the sketch to image
or sketch to anything
you are going to have to fine-tune it on
that data set but if you do you can see
that the results
are
very very
cool uh very accurate so this is the
input i'm going to guess that green
thing here is the vehicle class or even
the bus
class
and uh
yeah the outputs are are pretty
convincing honestly
so
yeah if you if you want you can look at
the metrics yourself they have a bunch
of more more examples right here
as we said um
specifically
things like in-painting are
doing are
quite uh possible right now so you can
say i want to only produce
so i want to clamp everything to the
original image except this region right
here you can give a piece of
conditioning text and
that together will
this so this is newer this is the
baseline right here will as you can see
fill in the missing pixels in order to
also match up with the text because it's
been trained
on text to image
data sets
yeah lastly this video manipulation
which was one of the sort of appraisals
of this paper right here you can see the
raw video on top the first row is
the
diver is swimming to the surface that's
given to the model so the model is asked
to manipulate the video in that way that
we're swimming to the bottom
or the diver is flying to the sky
which
surprisingly the model can do as well
now again i think i think the model
simply gets the first frame and then
needs to continue the video i don't
think the rest of the video has given us
conditioning information but i might be
wrong right
so
in if i'm right it would not necessarily
be video manipulation
but more kind of like video completion
conditioned on text but still is pretty
cool
all right so
yeah they have a by the way they have a
big appendix um they also compare like
different local attention mechanisms um
they have much more output right here
yeah i some sometimes it's it's very
funny but
i hope the code is out soon or is
already out and i just haven't hadn't
found it
as a conclusion they say they present
nua a unified pre-trained model that can
generate new or manipulate existing
images and videos for eight visual
synthesis tasks again caveat here is
that
only very few only like two or three of
those are actually zero shot maybe or
resulting from the pre-training for the
rest you actually have to fine-tune
several contributions are made including
a general 3d encoder decoder framework
covering text images and videos at the
same time that's what we saw
is possible by doing this essentially it
it's a it's a vq gan for images
for text it's already in the correct
representation and for um
for videos they simply say well every
frame is an image so it's like
yeah general encoder decoder framework
covering text images and videos is let's
say it's a nice formulation a nearby
sparse attention mechanism that
considers the nearby characteristic of
both spatial and temporal axes um that
is simply local attention so this nearby
sparse attention it simply is local
attention they simply do it
um
over
the three axes instead of over one axis
where local attention was originally
presented and third comprehensive
experiments on eight synthesis tasks
yeah that is
that is what they do
this is our first step towards building
an ai platform to enable visual world
creation and help content creators yeah
i can imagine that like models like
these are going to be pretty powerful
for content creators
if you can if you can essentially input
arbitrary
modalities
and mix them together it's going to be
pretty cool
all right so that was uh nua
let me know what you think
and i'll see you next time bye bye